hallo freunde der sonne ich bin es
wieder bei eurem mieterin des vertrauens
heute ausnahmsweise nicht mit einem tee
sondern mit einem golden latein kurkuma
latte das zeug ist nicht nur 100%
instagram sondern auch sehr gesund
so heißt es vor kummer zu deutsch gelb
osc zu den gesündesten gewürzen auf der
welt das liegt daran dass in dieser
exotischen wurzel mindestens 90
unterschiedliche wirkstoffe enthalten
sind wenn die hautprobleme haarausfall
oder sogar probleme mit ein paar extra
putten hast mir dann einen ein kilogramm
beutel kurkuma unter die nase hält und
gemeint trinkt das x ich habe gelesen
dass ist gut ich behaupte mal dass ich
mich schon vor der ein oder anderen
krankheit bewahrt hat wirkung video
kurkuma enthält ein molekül namens
curcumin das ist übrigens auch
verantwortlich für diese intensive gelbe
phase aber nicht nur das die liste
wogegen curcumin helfen soll ist
beeindruckt krebs alzheimer alkohol card
erektionsstörung haarausfall
depressionen und vieles vieles mehr
wann immer ein wundermittel gegen eine
ganze liste verschiedenster krankheiten
wirken soll sollte eigentlich direkt das
bullshit o meter ausschlagen aber das
interessante an comin ist das ist
unglaublich viele wissenschaftliche
studien gibt auch klinische studien mit
menschen und das ist eher untypisch für
so ein klassisches durchschnitt
allheilmittel deshalb durch einen tee
oder ein kurkuma latte macht es euch
gemütlich wir schauen uns jetzt die
wissenschaft hinter diesem goldenen
zeugs etwas genauer an
[Musik]
ihr werdet im netz unzählige artikel
finden über kuhmann und das ist ein
potenzieller oder vielversprechender
wirkstoff sein könnte für verschiedene
krankheiten aber was heißt das überhaupt
genau um das zu verstehen müssen wir
erst mal wissen wie neue wirkstoffe
überhaupt entdeckt oder identifiziert
werden
und ich hoffe ihr habt es euch gemütlich
gemacht denn das wird jetzt ein kleiner
ausflug aber cloud mehr es lohnt sich
denn man hört ja ständig von
irgendwelchen neuen potentiellen
nadine und das was ich euch gleich
erzähle das wird euch noch oft helfen um
solche meldungen in zukunft besser
einordnen zu können also die suche nach
neuen wirkstoffen um eine krankheit zu
bekämpfen muss ich die krankheit erst
mal verstehen schnitt 1 die krankheit
auf schlüssel sagen wir bio logo finden
heraus dass eine bestimmte krebsart
durch ein bestimmtes mutiertes protein
verursacht und dafür gibt es beispiele
das heißt um diesen krebs zu bekämpfen
müssen wir dieses mutierte protein
ausschalten das protein wird zum target
ernannt also zum ziel oder zur
zielscheibe
gesucht wird jetzt ein wirkstoff der
dieses target abschließt also der dieses
protein deaktiviert ja und dann geht die
suche los screening bedeutet einfach
dass testen sehr viele substanzen das
heißt man nimmt ein haufen moleküle
es könnte natürlich sein dass können
auch welche sein die man im labor
hergestellt hat und schmeißt die jeweils
auf das tage drauf und schaut ob das
dabei ist dass das protein ausschaltet
muss man eins aber beachten was wir hier
brauchen ist eine spezifische wirkung
beispiel durchsetzen kann ich jedes
protein kaputt machen aber deswegen das
hitze noch lange kein antikrebsmittel
denn hitze machte jedes protein kaputt
und nicht nur gezielt das notierte krebs
protein und genauso gibt es auch
moleküle die alle möglichen effekte
haben die binden vielleicht ein bisschen
an dieses mutierte protein aber dafür
auch noch 100 andere proteine und gehen
irgendwelche chemischen reaktionen in
der zelle mit sachen die ihnen gerade
über den weg laufen
das können wir nicht gebrauchen was wir
brauchen ist ein spezifischer wirkstoff
der gezielt das mutierte protein
ausschaltet alles andere aber in ruhe
lässt zum glück können immer mehr
proteine gezielt ausgeschaltet werden
denn der schalter ist gewissermaßen in
die proteinstruktur eingebaut
also eine proteinstruktur könnt ihr euch
vorstellen wie so ein großes 3d origami
und viele proteine haben ein blog oder
eine tasche also enzyme zum beispiel
sind proteine mit seiner tasche und die
tasche ist wurde magic happens in diese
tasche passen nur bestimmte moleküle
manchmal vergleicht man
das system mit einem schlüssel schloss
prinzip und dieses schlüsselloch also
diese protein tasche die gilt es nun
anzugreifen wenn jetzt ein wirkstoff
molekül perfekt in diese tasche passt
dann kann es da quasi andocken und die
tasche blockieren und damit kann das
enzym seine aktivität nicht mehr
ausführen und ist damit ausgeschaltet
weil man sich nur bedingt theoretisch
erleiden kann wie so ein super passendes
molekül aussehen könnte verfährt man bei
einem screening nach dem prinzip
probieren über studieren man probiert
einfach ganz ganz viele moleküle aus das
können eine million sein oder noch mehr
jetzt denkt man sich gott wie soll das
funktionieren hat man dann eine million
reagenzgläser oder was gewissermaßen
schon nur in sehr kleinen maßstab mann
hinter zum beispiel solche 384 well
plates die sind in wirklichkeit ungefähr
so groß und haben dann in dem fall 384
so kleine ja reagenz gefäße da drin es
wäre dann für so ein klassisches
screening also hochdurchsatz screening
dann hat man diese plate und somit ihr
roboter und die kombinieren dann die
diesen plan reagenz gewesen dass
mutierte protein mit einem dieser
millionen substanzen hoffen dass da
irgendwo ein potenzieller wirkstoff
dabei ist man screen das ganze also
durch fehlte das ganze runter und geht
dann am ende mit den positiven hits in
die nächste und zelltests man nimmt dann
zum beispiel krebszellen und schauen ob
man mit hilfe dieser hit moleküle deren
wachstum stoppen kann oder man schaut ob
in den zellen das enzym noch aktiv ist
wenn man dieses molekül hinzu gibt
chemiker können die guten moleküle noch
weiter optimieren also die bauern hier
ein paar dumme ein und nehmen da ein
paar aus geben die dann wieder in den
biologen die testen die wieder in den
zellen und so weiter und nach vielen
vielen jahren arbeit schafft man es die
leicht zum nächsten schritt tierversuch
in der regel testet man zunächst an
mäusen die haben dann zum beispiel
diesen bestimmten krebs hat versucht man
sie zu heilen und schaut nach den
nebenwirkungen und wenn am ende immer
noch moleküle im rennen sind die gut
aussehen dann kann man in die klinischen
studien und nur klinische studien haben
aussagekraft über die wirksamkeit bei
menschen so kann
der wirkstoffsuche allgemein aussehen
die frage setzt wo genau ist der
aktuelle forschungsstand balkonien oder
sollte ich lieber sagen curcumin comen
hat sich bisher in unzähligen screenings
als positiver hin bemerkbar gemacht und
zwar für verschiedene tages das heißt ja
die liste die ich am anfang auf gezählt
habe sie wurde nicht von irgendwelchen
internetexperten erfunden sondern beruht
tatsächlich auf wissenschaftlichen
studien auch bei etlichen zehn studien
und auch bei einigen maus studien gab es
positive ergebnisse aber seltsamerweise
gibt es bisher keine belastbaren daten
aus klinischen studien menschen die
unser video der handystrahlung gesehen
habt wisst ihr das so genannte
randomisierte kontrollierte studien der
goldstandard der klinische studien sind
goldstandard keine dieser sorgfältig
durchgeführten studien zeigt für
irgendwelche benefits von curcumin und
wie gesagt nur klinische studien haben
aussagekraft über die wirksamkeit bei
menschen was ist da los es ist nicht
alles gold was gold aussieht chemische
hochstapler bei aller sorgfalt in der
wirkstoffentwicklung gibt es fiese
fallen
es gibt zum beispiel moleküle die man
als canaccord ist also als chemische
hochstapler oder trickbetrüger
bezeichnen kann
diese gesehen die wissenschaftler auf
die falsche fährte locken jetzt wird's
spannend aber um das zu verstehen müssen
wie ein bisschen tiefer in die chemie
eintauchen
haben ja gerade über das gezielte
ausschalten von proteinen gesprochen zum
beispiel durch das blockieren der tasche
aber woher wissen wir eigentlich dass
das passiert man kann ja proteine und
moleküle nicht mit dem bloßen auge sehen
und es gibt leider auch kein mikroskop
das gut genug wäre um einfach zu schauen
ob das molekül in die tasche geht aber
wissenschaftler sind gewitzte menschen
und haben verschiedene arten von tests
entwickelt essays nennt man diese tests
auch wenn wir diesen essays kann man
indirekt sehen ob es geklappt hat dann
gibt zum beispiel ein farbstoff hin zu
einem fluoreszenzfarbstoff der nur dann
aktiviert wenn das protein deaktiviert
wird das heißt wenn ich mein test
molekülen zu gebe und die lösung wird
grün
dann habe ich einen positiven hits oder
ich nehme krebszellen und schaue ob sie
meinen test molekül überleben und wenn
es sterben ist das natürlich auch ein
positives ergeben es gibt eine ganze
reihe verschiedener essays und man muss
immer mehrere verschiedene durchführen
um wirklich sicher zu gehen aber jetzt
gibt es die hier moleküle die zwar
positive hits generieren die aber falsch
positiv sind zum beispiel die lösung
wird grün aber nicht weil ein protein
ausgeschaltet wurde sondern weil das
molekül direkt den farbstoff einfach
angeschaltet hat oder die krebszelle
stirbt aber nicht wahr das molekül mit
dem protein integriert hat sondern weil
das molekül generell zellwände zerstört
und manche moleküle sind dazu in der
lage in vielen verschiedenen essays
positiv hits zu generieren einfach nur
weil sich chemisch sehr vielfältig aktiv
sind chemisch promis kurs könnte man
quasi sagen chemische hochstapler
resveratrol ist zum beispiel so ein
molekül das in allen möglichen essays
falsch positive hits aufzeigt
reparaturen habt ihr vielleicht schon
mal gehört das ist das molekül das
rotwein so gesund machen sollen aber ob
ein bisschen rotwein und gesund ist oder
nicht dazu haben wir auch schon dieses
video weil resveratrol und andere
hochstapler moleküle den wirkstoff
entwicklern das leben so schwer machen
haben sie sogar einen extra namen
bekommen nämlich hennessey interference
compounds kurz sie auch einfach genpool
sind wenn man aufgrund falsch
davids zeit geld und arbeit verschwindet
um einer falschen fährte nachzuforschen
tja und jetzt ratet mal was mit kuhmist
kubina pain in the ass
curcumin ist ein pain wie er im buche
steht in diesem kommentar artikel der
2014 in nature erschienen willkommen
aufgelistet unter den worst of denn das
also unter den schlimmsten übeltäter
seine chemische promiskuität befähigt
ist dazu sich durch viele gängige es ist
durchzuchecken es ist generell nicht
besonders stabil was chemisch heißt es
ist reaktiv es gibt allein viergängige
wege über die kubin leicht zu fallen
kann und die folgeprodukte können dann
ihrerseits wieder chemische reaktion
eingehen das erklärt auch warum gekommen
in den vortest so erfolgreich ist aber
bei vielen tierversuchen und spätestens
in den klinischen versuchen versagt aber
wenn coco bin so reaktiv ist und es mit
jedem treibt es da nicht auch giftig
eine reaktive substanz ist potenziell
schädlich weil sie im körper mit allem
möglichen reagieren kann und dabei
schäden hinterlassen
dabei kommen und vor allem bei kurkuma
dem gewürz ist das aber nicht der fall
zumindest erst ab konzentrationen die
wir praktisch nicht zu uns nehmen können
erst als enthält das gewürz kurkuma nur
1 bis 6 prozent kurkuma effektiv ist es
noch viel weniger
denn die so genannte bioverfügbarkeit
also wie viel wirklich im körper ankommt
beträgt gerade mal ein prozent was
meister wird ja wie soll ich sagen
einfach wieder ausgepackt ich meiner
kann man sich immerhin so was sparen
diesen willen können star ist jetzt gold
ist also beruhigend für irgendwelche
negativen effekte aber natürlich gilt
das auch für positive effekt also selbst
wenn es positive effekte gebe dann ist
die bioverfügbarkeit von koumen ohnehin
so lausig dass davon nicht wirklich viel
ankommt man muss ergänzt man kann die
bioverfügbarkeit von koumen erhöhen
indem man es mit ein bisschen pfeffer
kombiniert wegen kriterien aber es gibt
noch ein problem dokument baut sich viel
zu schnell ab weil es eben nicht
besonders stabil ist wirkstoffe die
auch wirklich zwei dem körper wirken
sollen haben meistens eine halbwertszeit
von mehreren stunden bei kommen sind es
nur wenige minuten dann nur noch die
frage wenn man das alles weiß wieso gibt
es dann immer noch so viele studien gute
frage
wissenschafts verschmutzung für den
mediziner chemiker johnson welt ist die
veröffentlichung positiver ergebnisse
von reaktions freudigen hochstapler
molekülen vergleichbar mit mühe auf die
straße werfen bzw
er spricht von klusen also verschmutzung
eine verschmutzung der
wissenschaftlichen veröffentlichungen
das sind jetzt sehr harte worte ich
würde es so einordnen
die forschung an kurkuma ist trotz der
studien fülle noch sehr am anfang und
obwohl das paper gibt die vorgehens
warnen und zb auch explizit vorkommen
steht die denn so eine riesenmenge an
positiven paper über cocu hingegen über
die so ein falsches ungleichgewicht
erzeugen und hinzu kommt das muss man
leider auch sagen dass manche
wissenschaftler überhaupt froh sind wenn
sie irgendwelche positiven hits
vorzuweisen haben weil sie leider unter
einem unglaublichen druck stehen
positive ergebnisse zu veröffentlichen
aber das ist ein problem das wir in
diesem video schon einmal besprochen
haben für unseren alltag heißt dass
kalkumer latte sieht super aus aber die
zuschreibung wundermittel das kommt eher
aus tradition und nicht aus der
wissenschaft und ich will den ganzen
youtuber und in flames an die darauf
schwören auch nicht vorwerfen dass sie
zu lügen oder sohn gottes willen
aber wohltuende erlebnisse von
einzelpersonen sind kein wirksamkeit
belegt wenn es mir nach diesem latte
blinden geht dann kann das an dem leute
die ihn ist kann aber auch an sonst was
wissenschaftlich ist bisher leider
nichts belegt und deswegen auch nada
prüft wenn ihr vorschläge ab dass sich
in zukunft noch wissenschaftlich prüfen
kann
schreibe es in die kommentare wir sehen
uns nächste woche und bis dahin lässt
sich sofort in die waschmaschine getan
aber kuba forever